par contre au zaïre ce matin depuis ce
matin il ya quelqu'un avec un oeil au
beurre noir c'est george foreman
oui atmosphère de fête populaire à
kinshasa capitale du zaïre à l'occasion
du combat de l'histoire opposant mohamed
ali au tenant du titre mondial des poids
lourds d'orge for emma ce nouveau combat
du siècle est effectivement entré dans
le domaine de l'histoire africaine
ce fut un très beau cadeau offert au
zaïre et au peuple africain tout entier
par le président de la république le
citoyen mobutu sésé séko d'ailleurs ce
championnat du monde hors du commun fut
une excellente affaire de promotion
touristique mais aussi et surtout une
affaire politico sportive ali avait
avoué son ambition en venant combattre
ici au zaïre il le souhaitait être un
élément précurseur celui qui allait
ramener au bercail
tous les noirs américains des états unis
ali devenait ainsi un symbole de plus il
se sent depuis toujours investie d'une
certaine mission sur terre il en est
persuadé
allah est avec lui cette mise en
condition psychologique a fortement
influencé le résultat du match
les airois n'ont jamais eu qu'un seul
favori mohame tél on le sent tibia au
stade du 20 mai clé fut ovationné son
adversaire tout aussi noir que lui fut
constamment sifflé
sur le plan sportif le combat fut très
moyen le quotidien est roi et lima dans
une édition spéciale titre alina pas
dans ces forêts man n'a pas cogner ce
fut un combat sans spectacle qui a déçu
le public
à mon avis on peut difficilement
associer les mots de spectacles et de
boxe c'est aussi sous-estimé l'exploit
réalisé par un homme de 32 ans qui
reprend son titre mondial après l'avoir
perdu injustement en 1967
c'est enfin nier l'intelligence la
science pugilistique d'un casus clé qui
volent vous le savez que le papillon et
pique comme une abeille ali renversant
tous les pronostics n'est pas surpris
fort et man ray certes fort et puissant
mais pas un grand boxeur il est trop
rudimentaire
surtout il manque complètement
l'intelligence de ring il ne m'a jamais
touché sérieusement choisir lui me
donner plus de mal je vais poursuivre ma
carrière et défendre mon titre mondial
comme d'habitude vous le voyez créé à
100 francs par et joshua redman lui
tient tout autre langage
j'ai commis l'erreur de prendre trop de
risques avec kelly qui est un maître en
matière d' obstruction je me suis épuisé
à le frapper sans résultats positifs
sans pouvoir le descendre après cinq
reprises
je me suis sentie sans force de plus ali
avait tout le pays pour lui ce
championnat du monde de boxe clé forman
sera finalement retransmis intégralement
sur cette même première chaîne demain
1er novembre à 15h30 commentaires de
pierre camp génie